artists actors people like that they
live in a very strange bubble of their
own their mollycoddled they're highly
privileged we're talking about
successful artists like George or Barbra
Streisand or any other you know really
successful performing artists they live
in a relatively small world the people
around them are very solicitous and
caring for them they have a worldview
that is therefore everything should be
given to everybody because everything
has been given to them if you run a
business if you are responsible for a
lot of people you come to grips with the
reality that you have to have discipline
you have to protect the enterprise in
order to take care of the employees so
therefore you can't be wasteful you
can't squander things or you jeopardize
other people so running a business gives
you a sense of of compassion that is
defined in different terms than someone
who just thinks of themselves as
generous who lives in a single low
environment we know that real compassion
the real benefits to the people the
working people of America will only take
place as long as America is healthy and
healthy means that we can oh 18 trillion
or 20 trillion dollars because that day
will cause all the working people in
America to suffer so the the actors that
the Hollywood crowd they're
understandably the victim of their own
special prejudice and being in Las Vegas
all my life we know about the Hollywood
people and we love them anyway George
Clooney is fun to be with
as I said in an earlier resort you just
have to watch your timing and I didn't
call the president
and George didn't call me in it he was
he was a little into the tequila and but
he is fun to be with he's a good
storyteller